عاصمه ايرلندا الشماليه هنا تقف هذه
الجداريات شاهده على استمرار التوتر
المنبعث من صراع استمر حتى نهايه القرن
الماضي وخلف اكثر من ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
قتيل وقرابه 50 الف جريح ثم جاء عام
1998 وجاءت معه اتفاقيه الجمعه العظيمه
لتحقيق نادي ماء ابناء الاقليم المضطرب
ولو الى حين
[تصفيق]
ابقت الاتفاقيه الاقليم جزءا من المملكه
المتحده دون اغلاق باب انفصاله عنها واسست
على مبدا التعاون بين اعداء الامس على امل
جعلهم حلفاء ولو مكرهين وبالفعل نجحت
الاتفاقيه في تقليص العنف بشكل كبير لكنها
لم توقفه تماما كما ان التوتر السياسي في
الاقليم على اشده بسبب شلل حكومه تقاسم
السلطه منذ انسحاب الحزب الوحدوي منها قبل
اكثر من عام احتجاجا على ترتيبات التجاره
في الاقليم بعد خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ما يريده الناس وياملون رؤيته ومؤسسات
ديمقراطيه فعاله وهذا غير متوفر لدينا
الان بسبب مقاطعه احد اكبر الاحزاب وهو
حزب الديمقراطيين الوحدويين هذا مصدر قلق
كبير
هذا القلق مبعثه ان تجميد حكومه الاقليم
يهدد اساس الاتفاقيه وهو مبدا تقاسم
السلطه فكيف ينعكس هذا على المواطنين
نحن محبطون بسبب عدم احراز تقدم بين
الاحزاب فهم لا يسعون للتفاهم فيما بينهم
تتسع بينهما بسبب الاضطراب السياسي لا شك
ان اتفاقيه الجمعه العظيمه سمحت لجيل كامل
من ابناء ايرلندا الشماليه ان ينشا في ظل
السلام وهذا امر ايجابي بالتاكيد لكن تبقى
مدينه بلفاست مدينه مقسمه بسور اعلى في
بعض اجزائه من سور برلين الشهيره هذا
السور الذي يسمى سور السلام يفصل بين
مناطق البروتستانت ومناطق الكاثوليك وتغلق
بواباته كل ليله في دلاله لا تخطئها العين
على هشاشه هذا السلام اسعد الله الصاوي
الجزيره بالفاست